Your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a message,
a Dawah center.
This center, this message, this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam. So
give generously and Allah Azza wa Jal
will give you even more.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends. You are on the right
channel. This is hijab channel, not my
channel, but we've got a very very
interesting
what the hell is this? I mean, this
isn't my channel. You
you know, you hijacked the introduction.
How dare you? When I'm talking, don't
raise your hand above this level, yeah?
Try try again. Try again. Try I wouldn't
want to raise my hand above
Don't raise your hand because you know,
when I raise my hand, it will land
somewhere, you know?
Okay guys. So basically we've got a very
interesting video. This is a video um
that we're going to react to inshallah.
I think it's very very beneficial. It
pertains to the family unit. It pertains
to divorces. It pertains to a lot of
stuff that the ummah's already going
through of the breakdown of the family
unit due to feminism
um and God knows what else. So before we
start, we want to make some disclaimers.
Our intentions, me and hijab intentions
is not ill. We do not mean to come here
or like put the sisters down. They're
our sisters, you know, like they say,
you know, water is thicker than blood
and iman is thicker than
um
uh sorry, uh water blood is thicker than
water and iman is thicker than blood. So
they're our sisters in in Islam and we
want the best for them. However, there
are things that are said, whoever it's
from, our sister or brother that needs
correcting, we have to correct. So we
want to do that in a nice manner,
inshallah. We want to start off by
reacting. It's a 34-minute episode.
Before you do so, can I just add one
more point?
Sure, please. I think that, you know,
like nowadays we're seeing more kind of
like
I would call it the gender wars where
we're kind of living in the age of the
gender wars cuz the red pill movement is
its effect on Muslim people. Obviously
feminism is its effect on Muslim people
as well. And what I think is very
important that in before starting you
know, these kinds of episodes as as
coming from a Muslim paradigm is that we
are attempting
to follow the paradigm of Islam. Yeah,
100%.
The Quran, the Sunnah, the 1,400 years
worth of tradition tradition. This is if
this is the aim, then we need to kind of
like make sure that everything is
filtered through that lens. If it's not,
then clearly that there must be
refutation. And I do believe that this
video
it
definitely satisfies the the threshold
of refutation. It it does and we will
tell you why it does. And when we do say
refutation, at the end of the day,
refutation is part of our religion. I
mean, we can be refuted, you know, if
you know,
and we have been refuted and we will
probably continue to be refuted. We have
not as long as it comes from a sincere
place. I'm not from opportunistic
people. That's a different story. So
let's get into inshallah and you can see
for yourself guys what we have that
concerns not us, but the ummah at large.
The environment around polygamy and what
happens in the aftermath of it um is
really toxic and judgy and negative.
There's a lot of pressure to react in a
certain way. There's a lot of pressure
to
uh accept and that being like the it's
like that's the automatic position. If
you're a Muslim, you accept what God
allows, so why are you struggling? Like
what's wrong with you? And it's bringing
your faith into question and you're
I hear it over and over. I I want I I
love Allah. I love this faith.
This is something that Allah Subhana wa
Ta'ala allowed. Why is it breaking me?
And and I think that's that's what I
want to talk about today.
So women are questioning
themselves, questioning their level of
faith because it is something that is
breaking them. Is that been the
experience that you've had with people
that you've spoken to and worked with? I
think that it's it's an opportunity to
put a wedge between a woman and Allah
Subhana wa Ta'ala if she thinks that
it's being positioned that Allah Azza wa
Jal allowed me to do this to you. Right.
So it's like the spiritual abuse. When
something's going to happen and then I
say I have this God card that says that
I can do it to you. So if you have a
problem with it, you have a problem with
God.
Right. Okay. Just to be just Yeah.
before the video starts because we don't
want the sisters to be like you didn't
put a beginning bit. In the beginning
bit, they make it very categorically
clear they do not have an issue with
polygamy itself. It's just from Allah.
Mhm. Um but when we watch the video, we
get to see they they they said they
wanted to touch upon the way the
polygamy is done the wrong way. So we're
going to see if they even touch upon
that.
Just to give that disclaimer, they said
that. Now going straight to this. Yeah.
I think what she said is highly
problematic because she is not giving an
example of where there is
uh there is a miscarriage of justice
from the Islamic paradigm. She's just
talking
plainly about polygamy
as an institution or as something, a
form of marriage that Islam allows. And
then she says that she uses keywords
which I think are quite disturbing.
Yeah. Uh and ones which we've seen
being used in feministic circles. Uh and
I do believe this is a kind of
micro-feminism where she starts by
saying
spiritual abuse. Okay, spiritual abuse.
Why is God doing this? The God card.
Well, the truth of the matter is this.
First and foremost, there are many
things in the religion of Islam in the
relationship context, whether
symmetrical or asymmetrical, which can
cause pain
uh to people, okay, whether it's
psychological pain or otherwise,
uh and which are allowed and which quite
frankly we're not seeing any noise from
individuals that will make videos like
this. And I'll give you just one example
to
to to kind of make it clearer. Okay.
Take an example of a woman and I'm not
saying, caveat this, it's asymmetrical.
Uh that in other words, it can't be done
to the other way around. Or and I'm not
saying also
that it's like for like. So put these
two caveats to the side.
If you take a woman for example that
wants to get married to the man. Yeah.
Okay.
Uh she wants to get married to a man and
her and let's say for example the man is
from a particular tribe or particular
ethnicity or particular race
and her mother is totally against such
marriage. Yeah. Her mother.
Uh maybe she doesn't like the man. Maybe
she has even justification from her
perspective not to like the man.
Mhm.
She feels like this man is no good for
her daughter.
Mhm. Yet the daughter decides to proceed
with the marriage
at the expense of her mother's
well-being, let's say, even for the sake
of argument. Or let's just say at the
expense of her mother's happiness,
contentment, approval, whatever word you
want to use. Mhm.
This actually does happen in society. I
think it's more sociologically,
potentially more sociologically
widespread than polygyny itself. Mhm.
But despite the fact that this is the
case, in this scenario, we don't find
any of these sisters or anybody in
general considering this to be morally
aberrational from within Islam or
outside of Islam.
Mhm. In other words, if a woman makes a
decision which has the net effect of
causing some
or a severe level of discomfort,
anxiety, depression, or any other word
that you would like to use, it's not
seen as spiritual abuse.
Mhm.
It's not seen as spiritual abuse because
Islam allows it despite the mother's
wish. Mhm. I'll give you another example
which is less sociologically prevalent,
but still something which the Sharia
allows.
Mhm.
If a man sees a wife his wife in bed
with another man, the Quran clearly
talks about a process of Lian.
Which actually happened with the Sahaba.
It happens it's been recorded in history
which basically allows the woman to have
the last say and therefore no action to
be taken
against the woman at all. In other
words, there's no retributive justice.
The he has just seen his wife, let's
say, having sex with another man, but
there is no retributive justice. Islam
allows it. It's no retributive justice
on a material level and Islam allows
that Mhm.
despite the fact that it causes pain to
men. This is still within the
relationship structure and in this case
there is asymmetry. So let me just get
this right because we need to drill the
make make it make it make it make it
make it make
one more example.
No, no, but on this one.
Okay, right.
A man sees his wife in bed with another
man. Yes.
Having sex. Yes. He goes to the
messenger of Allah, the Sahaba, and says
he said this.
And he's expecting, I'm sure, the
prophet to
understand. I'm talking about the Quran
itself.
No, no, I know, I know, but just so they
understand this is that the prophet
peace be upon him says I'm going to
slash you for slander. Can you imagine
on top of adding salt to the wound? And
then on top of that, what happens is the
ayah comes down saying that they take
four oaths each and the last oath will
be that Allah curse be upon them. And
this woman actually does that and she
totally
yani is The point being what to do?
would that be to the man?
be very painful, but the point is it's
not spiritual abuse. The reason why it's
not using the God card or spiritual
abuse despite the fact that it hurts the
man
Yes. is simply because Islam allows it.
Exactly.
Now I'll give you a third example,
right?
Exactly. That's the point.
The third example and it's may maybe
controversial. May many people don't
know this. But if for example a woman is
married to a a man Yeah. and she
divorces him and then after her death is
complete, she marries his brother, blood
brother. No.
Now that's going to hurt the man. Now
obviously the opposite can happen as
well, yeah? And once again, I'm not
claiming it's asymmetrical.
Yeah. But what I'm saying is
despite the fact that it will hurt the
man, it doesn't mean it's morally
illegitimate.
Or is it spiritual abuse? It's it's
spiritual abuse.
Now it's clearly in the pretext, not
even in the subtext of what these women
are saying here,
that just basically engaging in this act
itself is a kind of spiritual abuse.
Exactly.
This is verging on kufr.
I'm very sorry to say. To use that kind
of language with an institution that
Islam has allowed and she's not talking
about the abuse of it cuz I've heard
this clip more than once.
Yes, they're not. She's talking about
the institution itself.
Yes. This is verging on kufr.
I'm sorry to say. I'm not saying she has
fallen into kufr. I'm not saying she's a
kafir. Just be clear.
Yeah. I'm saying this is verging on kufr
that she is flirting with disbelief by
speaking of an institution that the
prophet of Islam himself Yes. he engaged
in that he he did it himself polygamy
with nine different women. We have clear
evidence that some of them were
discontented at least at some point.
Let's come to that. But despite that
it's not seen as using the God card of
spiritual abuse. Good. This tone I
believe is highly problematic.
It is it is. And it's totally unfair.
Exactly. Let's carry on so we can just
get a full grasp on what's going on here
because I'm still looking for the
problematic practice of polygamy which
they were going to talk about. And I
think that's dangerous especially
because we're talking about it not being
executed properly. We have the example
of the prophet
we know what it's supposed to look like.
So in the cases where it doesn't look
like that and the woman has an aversion
to her or she's struggling or there are
conversations that aren't being had
there's support that's missing. There
are there are spaces where she's being
shamed and judged and sometimes
ostracized by the community taking issue
with it.
Bullied into making a particular
decision or not making a particular
decision.
We need to talk about that.
Yes.
I think it's really important that we
talk about the fact that these sisters
it when it when it's not executed
properly
that they are
now
trying to manage the trauma
of being betrayed of being lied to of
being deceived.
They're now having to manage a
completely different dynamic in their
marriage in their family and then going
back to what you said on top of that to
now be shamed spiritually
because there's something wrong with
their faith because they're not just
smiling about it and accepting it it's
layer upon layer upon layer of trauma.
And
like I said like I said right at the
beginning we're not saying that polygamy
is wrong. Polygamy is a part So let's
just rewind a bit okay. So firstly it's
to me it's turning into a horror movie.
Yeah absolutely.
Trauma Absolutely. Bullying Yes. Um um
Betrayal. Betrayal. Um what was the
other one she used spiritual abuse? Yeah
yeah. To me it's just turning to a
absolute horror. Yeah yeah yeah. Now I
understand you can come and say to me
actually it is a horror for a woman no
problem. And nobody said it won't be. We
know now she used for example that how
the prophet used to do it. Okay let's
let's look at how the prophet done it.
Do you know that
was was coming with she made a food
plate and the Sahaba there. Imagine the
prophet sitting with the companions.
Yeah imagine in your house with your
boys you're sitting with your boys yeah.
And then your wife comes in and you have
a plate of dish unintentionally by your
other wife.
And she smashes the plate in front of
everybody bang. She smashes it.
You're talking about how the prophet
done it.
Does that this is the best these are
mothers the best of women to walk walk
this earth one of them yeah.
She's behaving like this.
This cons this this this thought process
of thinking that polygamy is going to be
something that's going to be
like hunky-dory rosy it's not the case.
These things can happen. It shows you
that if a man gets into this these
things can happen as long as a woman is
not transgressing. The point is this I
want to ask a very simple question.
What is because this is again giving a
disclaimer against we're not against
polygamy you turned it into a horror
movie. How could you not be against it?
All all these
words of like you know big words you
know bullying etc. etc.
Look what you've turned it into if a
sister her husband was getting into
polygamy and she watched this you would
destroy your house.
You you would be responsible destroying
the house because let me tell you
something
people can easily get manipulated okay
especially the society that you're
living in. If I have if for example
somebody suffers from a trauma for
example okay let's suppose a mother lost
a child and she goes to a household to
get some you know for them to you know
console her and you know and imagine
they added to her burden and said oh
your your child's going to be in
hellfire or your child
Have you aided that or have you aided
made it easy have you took burdens off
her added burdens to her
and that's exactly what you're doing.
And the point is this let me ask a
simple question.
As men I'm making very clear I've said
this publicly and I'll say it again
okay. Every man is polygamous. Any man
that says he's not polygamous he's a
liar. So to think that this this is how
this in envision in their mind they
think that there is one guy out there
every person practices polygamy or is
polygamous within their nature Muslim or
non-Muslim. I want to ask a simple
question. Please tell us cuz I can
easily come and say okay tell us the
correct way to do it.
And if you can tell us the correct way
to do it and if we do it will you be
happy? No.
So then what is the discussion at hand?
It's a good it's a good question and in
fact the Quran makes it clear
the Quran says you're not going to be
able to do justice between your wives
and if you if you try but it doesn't say
therefore this is stop doing your
spiritual abuse.
It doesn't say therefore stop using the
God card
and therefore it says
don't incline so much so you leave the
other one hanging. He's giving you
practical advice.
I'm afraid to say that this conversation
here as you've correctly said you've
identified it and characterized it
correctly. These women here are actually
characterizing an institution with the
most negative superlatives
most negative adjectives with with most
horrible of context.
I'm afraid to say that this is
anti-resilience. Like if if you want to
get someone tougher and stronger in life
you don't do so by if polygamy is a
difficult thing for women to do. Let's
be
you you you you you you you said it
yourself. For example what you correctly
said is that when you know
she she broke the plate and now we
actually commented about this in his
yeah he says that this is
something
similar to that. He's saying this is
from something that she done which is
involuntary actions and she's not held
to account for it in fact.
Islam is a is a religion of mercy okay.
But having said all of that to be honest
if you collect all of the examples of
where there has been transgressions like
this or there have been mishaps or
whatever from the mothers of the
believers of the thousands no but of the
thousands you will find a dozen maximum.
What we're what we're dealing with here
is a situation where individuals find it
okay to actually hold their husbands
judge jury and executioner as hostage to
some kind of injustice that perceived
injustice they think they're doing to
them. There is nothing inherently unjust
about being in a polygynous situation.
There is as much inherently unjust in
being in a polygynous situation as there
is of marrying a man who your mother
doesn't want you to marry
even though she's upset. If you are
unhappy at the fact that your husband
did something that hurt you you should
also be unhappy with the millions of
women out there in the Muslim world who
in some cases their mother some cases
their father because as we know some
mothers don't even need the wali right
like the Hanafi madhhab or so on in
order for the nikah to be sahih and
other madhhabs will remove the wali if
he's being unreasonable. So you it's
conceivable that the father doesn't even
get a say or is removed from the is
removed from the equation when it comes
to marriage and he is very unhappy but a
woman's right is spoken about then it's
not a woman's responsibility it's a
woman's privilege and her independence
it's not spiritual abuse here.
You see even if the mother is frail and
old and a woman herself it's not seen as
spiritual abuse or traumatic and how can
you as a woman get married and put your
mother in such traumatic experiences?
This is the kind of consistency that is
required if what we're saying here is to
moralize something okay is to look at
the detriments that it causes someone
psychologically at the expense of
someone else.
It seems to be that number one they
don't really have their morality and
moral theories and compass in order
number one. Number two sorry sorry to
say this but it does seem to be an
inqiyad issue a submission issue an
Islamic issue.
It's it's an issue of submission and
iman. If you truly believe in Allah
and you believe in his
rulings I'm sorry to say and you and you
have full faith in that and you did what
Allah said when he said
come into Islam all together you cannot
describe the situation of living in a
marriage which potentially be getting
all your rights as a first wife
in such traumatic fashion.
Polygamy is the most beautiful thing
that has been stipulated by Allah
because it lays down protocols how to
protect the look this this my friend
crazy. As sisters I would be your
sisters you guys our sisters well I
we're saying this cuz we love you guys
for the sake of Allah
we're just trying to make you understand
something okay.
If you are if you want women empowerment
and you care about your cool sisters
polygamy has been sent as a protocol to
help defend the rights of the second
third and fourth wife who in non-Muslim
terms or even some Muslim men who
practice in wrong way who have side
chicks misses and girlfriends Allah
stipulated that if the man wants to go
and do that he does it in the right way
by honoring her speaking to her father
doing the marriage giving her mahr
announcing the marriage not hidden. You
should be at the forefront forefront of
defending this because as a non-Muslim
woman a man if he was watching this I'll
say this is a horror movie. This is this
horror this polygamy this is I would I
would have been lying
I would say this is this is anti-Allah.
Yes this is and actually not only that
it would be spiritual abuse on the
person that's watching this. Yes because
they might want to come to Islam and
they'll think you know what they'll say
you know what this is
you spiritually
bankrupted me I'm finished. No no no
let's be honest let's carry on let's
carry on.
They went to liking this and responding
and fitting into what you need to fit
into or else there's something wrong
with you and I think on the
you know for a woman who identifies as
practicing and religious okay some
people are in a position where they
don't want to talk to a mental health
professional and they don't want so
let's look for answers in the deen
because this is something that the
religion brought so I need to find
answers there. And when you start to
search and see if you look up polygamy
in Arabic and in English and you want to
see what the scholarship have to say
about it the attitude
is less than helpful. There is a little
bit bit of giggle culture. Yeah, haha,
the women get jealous. Haha.
And it's not being taken seriously. And
you realize that, okay, there is no one
in the religious context who has my back
on this. In fact, the way that they're
talking about it, it's very surface
level and it stops at the this is
actually allowed in the religion. And of
course, you know, the men have to be
just and of course, do do do do. But
we're not talking about it seriously.
There's no nuance. There is no
there is no consideration for the
woman's position besides, you know,
sister, you have to be patient because
if a woman stepped out on her marriage,
the vicious, poisonous will throw her
out and get a
he could spit on camera, you know? But
in a man's position, as long as we get a
paper from the mosque and we cover it
up.
I think what she said in the beginning
there was extremely dangerous. And she
said that well, if you do I'm
paraphrasing, but if you do a search in
English or in Arabic, you'll find that
there's no it's not helpful and that
there's a giggle culture and all these
kind of things.
Giving us the impression that she's
already done this this this work and
that she's she's looked at all of the
resources that in English that are
available and all the resources that are
in Arabic that are available in the
Islamic tradition. Because if we talk
about scholarship, we're not talking
about the last 20 or 30 years. We are
talking about the last 1,400 years. We
are And by the way, that would include
Aisha and the the mothers of the
believers. That would include the female
scholars which she has uh
I've forgotten about quite frankly in
her in her tirade. But what I'm saying
here is
to put people away from the religious
discourse in favor of something else.
If not deviance, then what is it? No,
this is this is very dangerous because
the thing is what's being told is here
is this.
Um Islamically,
we're bankrupt. There's nothing to offer
here.
Exactly. And then she talks about coach
what she mentioned in the beginning
about
coach did she say or something like
therapy or something along those lines.
I mean, what you want us to do? Go to
the go to the non-Muslims? I mean, yes,
you can. There's nothing wrong with that
if you go for certain issues.
But what you've done is you've like as
if Islam has nothing to offer on this
matter.
Exactly. Yeah, it's finished. Go don't
Islam don't turn to Islam. Is this is is
the plea of psychological resources?
don't yes, it has nothing to offer like
as if Allah, the Quran, the Sunnah
there's nothing to offer. Now we're
going to have to go to
these therapists, whoever they are, God
knows.
One of them told me a story that sister
was going through something. She went to
this therapist, this non-Muslim
therapist. And you know what they said
to her? Explore your sexuality, go sleep
around. Yeah? Yeah, and they let's go to
these people. Go to individuals that are
not Muslim. Yeah, what do you think
they're going to say to you, my dear
sister? Let's suppose your husband is
going through is is getting married a
second wife, yeah? You go to a
therapist. And you say to the therapist,
my husband got married again. What do
you think she's going to say? Uh she's
going to give you ways of dealing with
it?
No, she's going to they're going to give
you deal ways of destroying it. Yeah?
Let's be honest, yeah? As a Muslim
woman, if you are so I'll be honest with
you, I see anger in your eyes.
I see anger in your eyes. Like my sister
I see if you're dealing with It can be
the case you have a neutral therapist
that won't get involved in moral issues.
But
you're right. The point stands which is
that she is clearly pushing people away
from the religious discourse. She is
offering them she's saying that this
does not have the resources for your
psychological concern.
is which is dangerous. The thing is,
bro, if she as a Muslim Look at these
are free these are free sisters who are
up to the hijab. They are believing
women who fear Allah.
I we have to believe they fear Allah. If
they are coming and saying this, yeah,
akhi, why am I going to speak from a
non-Muslim woman? If the believing women
are coming and giving our sisters this
advice, I'm so sorry. I'm not saying
they intentionally have a malicious
intent. I do not mean that. But if you
guys can so it's an emotional statement.
I'm sorry, I've not to Quran and Sunnah.
I've heard emotional statements.
Actually, they don't mention the Quran
and Sunnah at all in this video.
Exactly. Okay, okay. Okay, if that's the
case, if you guys are mentioning this as
sisters, imagine a cool sister coming to
you guys and thinking hijabi, Muslim,
believing, what advice are you going to
give me? My husband got second wife. I
swear to God that woman will leave the
meeting a blackmailing her husband,
probably using the kids against her
him. He'll do all all kinds of stuff,
right? Cuz she will say like they say,
because you've done this to me and
spiritual abuse and bullying.
That is she will leave that meeting Yes,
yes. devastated. The thing is the the
issue is it gets worse when she starts
saying that the the the scholars or
whoever is religious clergyman, they say
um you know, let's be patient and and
she says that's only uh Yeah, why not
Patience Patience is one of the deepest
Why not patience?
Patience is one of the most deep and
important uh part of Islam. Yeah,
aspects of the religion of Islam. So,
what I'm saying is that if if someone's
giving you the advice Yeah. which Allah
gives you in the Quran Yes. which is
what Allah says about patience.
Literally, what Allah says about
patience exhort one another to patience
and you're ridiculing them. No, no,
you're ridiculing them on the basis that
they are doing exactly what the Quran
tells them to do by the word. And
Do you think you're following the Quran
or your own desires?
Wallahi, I can even tell you something.
Like Allah says in the Quran,
in Allah says yeah.
Akhi, wallahi, when Allah says
something, verily with hardship comes
ease.
Indeed with hardship comes ease.
Wallahi, wallahi, if a sister comes to
me and says my husband got
married again. I'll ask her some basic
questions. Sister, does he pray? Yes,
does he practice good? Is he
holistically whole in totality is he a
good guy? Yes. Does he provide? Does he
all these kind of stuff? Here's what the
sister said. Stay with him, sister.
Wallahi al-Azim, you go these sisters,
they listen to their friends, these
friends, okay?
What, he did that to you? Ah ah ah,
please please shut up. Shut up. Yeah,
don't act like your husband's not
polygamous. Don't act like your husband
is not doing it in either we hope he
does it in the halal way or in the haram
way, yeah? Stop acting like your husband
every man is polygamous. You're going to
destroy that house. Sister, you're going
to believe it and destroy your house.
And guess what? Those friends are not
going to be there for you. I promise
you. The reason I'm saying is this. You
get in a hype and you believe these
sisters, etc. Now you they can say
something very easily.
And and please they're going to come and
say you guys you guys are men. It's easy
for you to say. Oh, masha Allah. Like
the giggle culture. No problem. Check
this out. Check this out. Check this
out. No problem. No problem. No problem.
Check this out, bro, yeah? Okay. What
does Allah say that we as men have to
do? We're the maintainers and the
protectors. No problem. That means when
a thief comes to the house, brother, am
I going to send my wife or am I going?
No, you're going yourself.
Am I am I the maintainer? I pay for the
bill, electricity, gas, water. You have
I think you're going to kind of gather
you know No, no.
Alhamdulillah. You're in a giggle
culture for the rest Alhamdulillah, my
wife is watching this. She knows wallahi
I do not like I tell her she she loves
being a mother. It's the best thing.
Wallahi, I see happiness in her
in her eyes when she's with our kids,
yeah? The point is this, bro.
On top of that, add this. When a war
happens, what's happening in Ukraine?
Yeah? What's happening? Bro, even the
transgender women are being stopped.
Yeah, yeah, no, no, no, you're a man
now. You're a man now,
I'm going to ask a simple question, bro.
If we are called let's say if if if a
war happens, argument's sake, let's say,
yeah? And we and we we attend. Do you
love going to war?
Me personally? Yeah, I'm asking you.
You're asking the wrong
What Do you look forward to going to
war? No, I know one more. Okay, okay. Do
you look forward to going and saying my
limb might come off? No, no. Actually,
you know what? I might not come home.
Actually, you know what? No, one second.
Actually, forget the getting I'm with
you, Ali. Okay. Imagine you don't even
come home at all. And your Imagine the
thought for every man we have
Imagine your wife might go like I would
if I pass away,
my wife's going to go and marry someone
else. Which one's which one's worse? You
have a husband that has another wife,
but he's still in your life and your
kids' life. But compared to what we're
going to go through when we go to war,
the the chance of being killed, number
two, not returning home. Can I come and
say,
"But this is not fair, man. This is
spiritual abuse, man." My wife will be
the first one to say, "Get out there and
defend." It's true. It's true. Am I
going to complain? We accept what Allah
has legislated for us which is much
harder. I'll be honest with you than
polygamy because we're going to end up
dying and get a limb chopped in some
instances. Then how can you come here
and use these kind of words? I think
what you said in this
you're getting very emotional. No, I
would like you cuz you know why?
You know why, bro? It hurts me to see
the breakdown of the family unit.
But what I will say is this, bro, is
like honestly, yeah? One thing you did
say which is I think completely true,
yeah?
Is that individuals like sister Sumaya
here, yeah? She will give advice to
other sisters
as she would in the end of this episode,
we'll see that. You know, sometimes the
individual is more important than the
whole is cuz the individual she will say
in her own articulation.
But basically in directing the device
for divorce. And she we've we've already
dealt with this in previous episodes.
That she does this quite often. And she
seems like it's her favorite type of
advice.
But then she is not going to be there
monetarily or otherwise for the sister
that is going to be stuck with
I don't know how many children even if
she's alone with that with that and
she's not going to be there to to to to
assist to help sorry to say to
physically assist to sexually satisfy.
You don't have the facility to deal with
all of that. To psychologically be a
companion for that individual.
And you don't even want or have told
your people that are listening to this,
yes, who are very impressionable and
probably going through a very difficult
situation.
You haven't even told them. You haven't
gone as far as to even tell them that in
fact they're in for a long period of
grieving and heartbreak.
Why don't you tell them about the fact
that if you leave and if you try and
break your home, not only will you be
grieving, your children will be
grieving. There'll be heartbreak
everywhere. Look at the studies on
single parent homes, yeah? We're not
blaming the mother. What we're saying is
in single mother homes, bro,
it's it destroys the family unit, bro.
Especially the children. How could
someone be so self-selfish? And look, I
don't know if these sisters have gone
through it personally themselves. But if
they if they have or they haven't, if
they have, bro, it is dangerous for you
to use something which you may have
disliked Let's suppose argument's sake
he happened the wrong way. He did it the
wrong way. Then you to come and use that
bitterness to take out on the whole
ummah. Because now what you're doing is
you're giving advice to these sisters
based on something that you lived
through which was let's say done the
wrong way. Okay, let's suppose that
polygamy that your husband done was the
wrong way. And now you're out bitter,
hurt, and you are channeling that energy
in such a way that it is destroying the
family unit, the households.
It's irresponsible behavior. Absolutely.
Let's see what else they are saying.
I'm again, I am hearing from sisters
who come crying
and distraught distressed on the floor.
My husband has married behind my back.
Or my husband is you know has told me
that he wants to get married and I just
I Do you know what gets me though?
What is a man
ex- who does that expecting?
I think he's You know what he's
expecting?
This is my honest opinion. This is just
my opinion. When you know when sh- we're
not here we're not saying you know this
is we're just this is just a discussion.
I believe a lot of men who go and do it
in that way in the wrong way. And there
are going to be people there are going
to be people that are going to be saying
but you know what sh- so and so and
Islamically you don't have to tell your
wife but anyway that's a side point.
Let's talk morally.
You love someone you would.
You see what she's done here? It's It
was It was a It was a very
subtle subtle thing very nuanced thing
but I think we both saw what happened.
Yes. Yes. Sh- so and so said something
but morally. Yeah so basically what the
sh- saying is immoral
and the moral thing to do is this. No
the issue is deep because what are we
saying that morality is to be found
outside of the the fatwa framework? Are
we saying now morality is to be found
outside of the religious framework?
Yes. And and do you know how she
justified it? She said that you if you
love your wife XYZ.
No but that's not how we define our
morality.
In other words we don't we don't decide
what is right and wrong based on the
empathetic love that we have for
someone. In fact someone called Paul
Bloom wrote a book called Against
Empathy. Yeah. And in that book he
actually makes a very strong argument
against using empathy as a means of
moralizing certain morality. For example
he says
if I'll give you an example he doesn't
use this but you know I'll use it. There
was this girl young girl that got lost.
Yeah Madeleine McCann yeah. Madeline
yeah. Yeah yeah. Madeline got lost. She
was a white girl that got lost. And
obviously it's a tragic situation. Yeah.
But the fact that she was on the
newspapers and that she was on the front
headlines all kind of things. It made us
empathize with her. But the fact of the
matter is that girls are being human
trafficked they're being sold into
slavery and
on a on a monthly basis from all kinds
of ethnic backgrounds not just white
Caucasian girls.
The truth of the of the matter is this
is that we have a a disproportionate
consideration for Madeline because we
have been exposed to her story. We
haven't been exposed to the all these
other stories. In other words we've been
made to empathize with her.
Paul Bloom therefore he makes the
argument that if we were to use empathy
as a means to try and moralize or
generalize moralities then it would be
enumerate it would be discriminatory
and it would be problematic for the
reasons aforementioned. So when women
sorry to say men and women it's not just
a woman thing but women like this for
example who are talking about poly-
polygamy and sharing their anecdotal
experiences and quote unquote traumas.
Yes when they are talking about these
matters
and then they are forcing an empathetic
response or they are let's say
generating an empathetic response from
another woman
what becomes blurred are the moral
guidelines.
Morality becomes descri- described and
defined as per
the emotional feelings of that
individual. How could he make you feel
like that? How can this someone who
truly loves you do something which hurts
you like that? Morality becomes defined
in the way that she's just detailed.
If if if you love someone in conditional
terms if you love someone why would you
do such a thing to hurt them?
But and because doing so according to
her would be immoral. But that
formulation of morality number one is
unsubstantiated in the academic
literature.
Number two is actually refuted in the
academic literature
as mentioned in the in the book Against
Empathy it's an interesting side point.
And thirdly it's totally un-Islamic from
an Islamic perspective.
So so so what No I'm just I'm just
saying that all I'm saying here is that
if you're saying we have a paradigm
which is the paradigm of morality
and then you have the paradigm of fatwa
or what this sh- said this sh- this sh-
said that.
Why are you exploring a paradigm outside
of the paradigm of Islam if indeed you
truly believe the paradigm of Islam?
Have they have they been given
permission which Allah has not given
them permission for? Have they have they
have they created legislation which
Allah has not given them permission for?
So this is legislation that is coming
outside of the Islamic paradigm. This is
the this is the
This is the danger.
Yeah this is the danger of speaking
without knowledge as they are. This is
the danger of using emotional judgment.
This is the danger of speaking on camera
on issues that can break households and
allow children who quite frankly women
like this with all selfishness egoism I
don't think are very concerned about the
children. They mentioned them in the end
very passingly. But putting children in
a situation of disadvantage sociological
disadvantage because you're not
encouraging women to be resilient on a
thing that Allah allowed and the prophet
practiced instead you're giving them all
ammunition
with the most with the most dangerous of
wording lethal ammunition lethal
ammunition with
tendencies. Yes absolutely no doubt
about it. In fact they are more In my
opinion wallahi
and Allah is my witness to conservative
or traditionalist women these women here
are more dangerous than any feminist
because they creep in.
Because when a Muslim woman is watching
a non-Muslim
they'll say
this they're they're not Muslim they
don't understand how Islam works etc.
When they're watching a group of our
sisters who are in hijab who are using
some Islamic terminologies they are more
prone to take it.
And that is what dangerous and let's not
look far bro. We was talking about
empathy and stuff like that yeah.
Didn't companions have to fight their
own family members who are blood who
they loved?
Did they not have to do that?
find you in the battlefield son Wow if I
find you in the battle
Ali Islam we don't need to look for the
Noah Islam. Say oh Allah did you not say
you're going to save my family? He loved
his son he wanted his son to be saved.
What did Allah say? Allah subhana wa
ta'ala rebuked the Noah Islam and he
said oh no that your family is who? The
believers yeah not your not blood. Don't
think your blood son. He loved his son
he was upset he was crying that like the
fact that he was drowned but Allah had
to remind him to take the nakal over the
akal because if you go to the akal what
does akal say? I love him. Well the
person sahaba had to fight in a battle
the people that they loved.
Let's carry on. And yeah and this is a
common occurrence and quite frankly
people that convert to Islam like
yourself you have to deal with
people like yourself on a daily basis
have to deal with unruly unruly and
cantankerous rambunctious individuals
who make their life hell okay? And it's
but they're doing it for the sake of
Allah.
Which is why quite frankly we'll find a
lot of people who do practice polygamy
are people from the revert community
because they have they have decided to
strip away all the cultural baggage.
They have decided not to listen to
Islamic advice. I'm so sorry. I see more
revert sisters wallahi more humble when
it comes to this thing yeah. Okay and I
don't know anyways I don't want to get
into it man just let's just let's just
see what else they have to say. And
maybe the answer won't be clear
immediately and you need time.
You want to try it out you want to see
how it goes you need the flexibility you
need time to make to make your decision.
I think the second thing is talking to
the women. See how she she addresses
women in a way that as if they can just
throw talaq on the man.
What do you mean make your decision?
If you your only decision you have to
make is to ask your husband or go to a
sharia council and follow the procedure.
You're not you do not have the same
rights as a man. She's the assumption of
equality is almost clear in her subtext.
What do you mean make your decision?
It's not you cannot wake up in the
morning and make a decision. Doesn't
work like that. There are many things at
play and there are many stake-
stakeholders at play.
I feel like what she's doing here she's
removing all the Islamic apparatus and
she's trying to create a system of
equality. Even if it wasn't in English
law she would have to go to the
solicitors and she'd have to file for
certain things. She'd have to negotiate
certain matters.
It's it's it's a false illusion that she
can do what she wants.
It's about this. You can just like you
said make a choice to enter to say you
know what I'm down with this I'm cool
with it I want to come into the picture
of a family already and enter.
You need to be educating yourself about
what that's going to entail. You need to
be realistic about what that's going to
mean. You need to be honest about what
you're actually looking for and what
you're actually expecting. I don't think
the old bait and switch is just going to
cause trouble. I'm I'm cool to renounce
my rights. I don't need financial
support. I am going to be easy. I'm not
going to disrupt anything. I just need
you know
but are you being honest about what
that's what that's going to mean and
you're cool with it.
First wife is being bullied and I've
heard this multiple times in particular
cultures it's more emphasized than
others.
You can't tell your family I did this.
You not only have to handle the pain but
you have to keep it a secret because if
you tell your parents that I did this we
know it's going to kick off.
Okay so what's the problem with that?
Okay okay one sec one sec one sec. All
right let me get this right. Okay look
let's make it very simple and clear.
Okay I I want I want you know what I
want from our sisters honesty too. Okay
please can you do an episode yeah? And
in that episode please can you tell us
brothers wallahi we want to know. I want
to know. Please tell us the right way to
do I'm going to do the right way. Yeah?
Not that I'm saying I'm intending on
doing it but what I'm saying is that
please tell us men what is the right way
to go about it without all the drama of
our wife and her telling that not
telling her parents cuz she
just go away from all of that. Please
can you tell us how you sisters or the
females will be happy for us to prac-
practice polygamy in the correct manner?
Please tell us. I bet you you will not
be doing that episode because you do not
believe there is a correct way. The best
way of polygamy for you guys is no
polygamy. That's what it is. Best
polygamy no polygamy. That's the issue
here.
Um and what did she say?
She She said about um being bullied.
Okay. Look, bro, this the hypocrisy that
I see. I'm so sorry. Wallahi, let me
tell you something, yeah. Let's go to a
brother, yeah. Get the brother and go to
his in-laws and say, "What kind of
brother is this?" He laughs. "Yes, he's
good to my daughter. He provides. He's
very good. He helps us." Okay, good good
good. Go and ask the same family and
say, "You know what? You know your
son-in-law, yeah? He got a second wife."
"I've never seen any good in him." La
ilaha illallah. What happened 2 seconds
before? A minute ago he was the best
guy. Because of polygamy? Bro, wallahi
wallahi This is why the prophet peace be
upon him peace be upon him said, "Glad
tidings to the strangers." They have
become strangers, akhi. For them to
practice something which is from the
Sunnah, and I'm talking about brothers
who are good to their wives, who are
just to their wives, who provide for
their wives. I'm talking about these
men. I'm not talking about these guys
who do not pray, don't practice, they
cheat, they do I'm not talking about
them. These kind of men who are
practicing are being shunned. They are
being made They're being ostracized. To
make They You're making them feel And
then on top of that, of course he's
going to come and tell you not to tell
your family. Because your family see
this as something ugly, as something
evil. And guess what? You're probably
your your your own um dad prac-
practices polygamy. Mhm. Yes. Wallahi,
astaghfirullah. The same dad practices
polygamy. Yes, yes. He practices it. But
when his son-in-law does it, that's why
I did an interview with one brother. He
said, "Would you want that for your
daughter?" I said, "Akhi, how can I
stand in front of Allah and say I want
it I I'm a I'm a
Every man is polygamous by their nature,
yeah? How can I come and say um
I might do it, but for my uh daughter,
la. Wallahi wallahi wallahi wallahi Like
the prophet peace be upon him said, "If
Fatima was to steal our Quran." We don't
rule with hypocrisy. One rule One rule
for me, another rule for my daughter. No
no no no no. If my daughter is happy,
she's she she's happy with it, I'll tell
her here's the pros and cons, etc. Here
I've done it. I will not come and say
he's a bad guy, he's an evil guy. This
is something from the deen. How are you
making it something horror, evil,
bullying, spiritual abuse, betrayal,
lie. Wallahi, this is like paranoia
activity. Yes, absolutely. So so so so
so so so so so so so so so so so so
Yeah. That's what it's turned into. She
has. A in in a moral Islamic manner.
With ihsan. With ihsan. In a humane
manner. Seeing that that the the the
woman the women are actually human
beings. They're not property.
They're not just nothing. They have got
souls. They have got emotions. They have
got thoughts. They have got wants.
They've got desires.
And that's okay for them to have.
Right? I think many of us, women and
men, have yet to even fully accepted
that that's the case. Like a woman
You're dealing with a whole person.
Okay, no problem. You're dealing with a
whole person, too. Mhm. Is your husband
a whole person? Does he have desires and
emotions?
Wallahi, akhi, look, we understand we
accept our sisters. We accept the Muslim
Muslim woman woman with her true nature.
You are hypergamous by your nature. You
look for a man who is taller than you,
who can provide security, who can
provide for you, who can do many things,
who's who's a more maybe leader. You
look for these properties. That's what
your nature inherently has. Do we
complain about it? No, we try to be that
best person that we can so you can
select us. Yeah? Why is it that when it
comes to our nature, which is a
polygamous nature, we are shunned? Why
is the double standards? We accept you
with your hypergamous nature. No
problem. Why do you not accept us with a
polygamous nature? Why are we shunned?
Why are we ostracized? Why am I a good
for brother? Did I You know what,
brother? Did I choose to be polygamous?
Did I choose to have these desires? No,
Allah created me like that. Mhm. Go and
take it out. Now, if I say this you're
going to say, "Oh, spiritual abuse. Uh
now you're using the God card."
Well, you're you're finished. I'm asking
a simple question. I think being a man
how that is a spiritual abuse
Well, akhi, it's finished. Wallahi, YOU
CAN'T YOU CAN'T
THE POINT THE POINT THE POINT here is
this, yeah? No man Let me tell you
something, wallahi, akhi, yeah? Okay.
Let me tell you something, yeah? No man
No man, yeah? Look, I have a wife. I
love my wife. I do not wake up one day
and go
"Let me practice polygamy and let me
destroy her." I Akhi, what the hell are
you talking about? No man wakes up and
says, "Let me break my family. Let me
Let me make my wife upset." No. What
we're saying is inherently as men, we
are polygamous by our nature. Okay? Some
choose to practice it. Most want to
practice it. They can't because of many
other reasons. But the point is we are
all polygamous via our nature. We do not
do this to hurt our families. Why would
I wake up one day and destroy my whole
family? No. Understand that that's
within our nature. Okay? And if we was
to go about it and do it the right way,
which you guys haven't given us an
option. You know, what is the right way?
Nothing. Why are we to blame? Why are we
made to be evil? The question I'm asking
is this. Why does a good Muslim man who
wants to practice polygamy become bad?
Please tell me what makes him bad in the
split second
split second decision of wanting to get
a co-wife? Please tell me, why is he
evil? Because you are brainwashed to the
current standards of monogamy. Yes?
Monogamy is a new concept. It's a new
phenomena. Not from day Adam it's been
polygamy. That is the norm. You've been
watching too much Hollywood, Bollywood,
and all these kind of movies that's made
you to believe one man one woman. And
guess what? Most women that's watching
this will know. Okay? And I'll bet
anybody
you have in one moment of time,
practicing or non-practicing,
caught your husband or your boyfriend
speaking to another girl or or
something. Why are men doing this? Well,
like akhi, if there was a study done
and if the study showed that every woman
on on planet Earth wanted a Gucci bag, I
would have to say to myself there is
inherently something within a woman that
loves a Gucci bag. Mhm. Why do they like
it? Because it's cross-culturally across
the globe they have this phenomena.
I think you're you're making a good
point because The point The point Just
to finish on this. The point is this. I
would have to come and say, "Okay, there
is something wired within a woman's
brain that she likes a Gucci bag." Mhm.
I would have to accept that reality Yes.
and be like, "Okay, how do we deal with
it?" Okay, it's fine. Yes. Why is it
that when a man wants to practice
polygamy in a right way,
you look at all the stuff that you've
said, and then how could a man come to
you and that be like after all the
bullying, all the words you used, which
man in their right mind would open up to
you and say, "Look, I want to get a
second wife." Which man? Yeah. Good
point. And I will say, "Look, there's
something else I would add to this,
which is that you mentioned that this
has been going on across culturally and
historically."
Uh actually, I think from what I
remember Britannica University uh
Encyclopedia, it said 85 to 95% of world
civilizations before the current age,
i.e. the last 100 years, were permitted
polygyny. So, if it's the case
all do it practice in spiritual abuse?
No no. It's It's what I'm saying here.
Good. It's What What I'm saying is here
if if this is a normal psychological
reaction,
in other words, to consider this to be
spiritual abuse, to consider this a then
we should have seen a wealth of
historical evidence
Yeah. from thousands of years up until
the present age. We should have seen a
wealth of historical information,
testimonials from women all considering
it to be, in your words, traumatic,
abusive, it's using the God card,
bullying, uh laying on the string and
pretending to
wanting to commit suicide.
Suicide. Suicide ideation.
Dropped dropped on the floor. All those
things, all those kind of wording that
you're using. Yeah. We're not We We
simply don't have any historical
evidence in 1,400 years
Yeah. to indicate anything more that
than the fact that yes, they did cause
and we have to be very honest and just.
Yes. It does cause and did cause
historically levels of jealousy,
anxiety, Don't tell me
anger, frustration, all kinds of
discomfort for women. Yeah. But not to
the level what they're they're they're
describing here. This This kind of
testimonial here is absent in the
historical record. No no. the fact that
even non-Muslim societies were
practicing these kind of things. Yes.
Even today. I mean, you go to Nigeria.
I've just been to Nigeria.
Nigeria, bro. Christian people were
practicing Yeah, I can't forget
Christian, akhi. Non-Muslims today in
the West are practicing it.
Thank you very much.
What dream are we living in, man? I
don't know. Non-Muslim Non-Muslim men
are practicing it. Yes, they are.
Wallahi, you can't Look, mistresses,
girlfriends, side chicks. They are doing
it like it's happy days. Or serial
monogamists. Yes, bro, serial
monogamists. Why the serial monogamists?
Why is Hugh Hefner and Donald Trump
serial monogamists? Because they're
looking and they're thinking their wife
has reached 40 45 years old, 50 years
old, cannot produce kids anymore, and
biologically that's biologically we're
not having a kid.
Then the thing is here is that Hold on a
second. They're thinking if I go and
tell her about a second, they're like,
"Okay, I'll divorce her." These women
end up dying alone with a cat.
That's reality because a man's biology
he can carry on. So, the thing is
they're thinking, "Okay, I'll divorce
her and go get a new model."
And that's what's happening. And guess
what? They are practicing polygamy. What
they've done is in the wrong way by
leaving one wife who's given his life,
breaking That's what you call breaking
because he is abandoning her. That's the
worst type of That's akhi, can you
imagine? Akhi, let me tell you
something. A man This is another issue
that sisters have is this. They think
that we love the way they love. When a
woman loves one person, she's bound to
cuz she's wired like that. She loves one
man. The moment she falls out out of
love in one man, she tends to start her
uh divorce period long time 2 years. So,
some brothers come and say, "Oh, my my
wife divorced me and moved on fast."
It's like, "Brother, that divorce
happened 2 years ago. You're sleeping."
Yeah? So, the thing is they And they
think that's how we love. No, it doesn't
work like that.
Mhm. For a man, it's like a woman who
loves her kids. If you go and say,
"Which kid do you love the most?" Say,
"I love them both the same." Okay? So,
for a man, it's like that. We don't love
the way you love. That's why you think
when a man gets a second wife, you think
he doesn't love me anymore. There's
something wrong with me. Wallahi,
brothers that I know who practice
polygamy, most of them when it doesn't
go right, things go sour, they go back
to the first wife. Why? Because they
never had a problem with them in the
first place.
The point is this. They go back to the
first wife. The point is if he didn't
like you, he would have left you.
There's a talaq. Bye-bye. I want to move
on. I'm not happy with you. That is not
the case. We don't work the way you
work. We're not wired the way you're
wired.
Thank you very much. Let's Let's hear
one more one more point. She's dealing
with a shadow.
An actual human being. And to come with
that level of emotional maturity,
intelligence, and
just ihsan.
Respect and consideration. That was my
last point.
your last point. Your final thought.
My final point, I think, in the cases of
polygamy, the woman who finds herself in
position in that position, like in the
case of a person who's on the fence
about divorce from a a marriage, um I
think the advice tends to be that we
need to maintain the the the
institution. We need to keep the house
intact
even if it's going to be at the expense
of the individuals who comprise it. And
I think that's a dangerous bit of
advice. Wallahi sister, you should come
off social media. Immediately.
Because of this No, no, let me tell you
something. Because of this advice, I
swear to God, sister, with all due
respect, wallahi, I don't know if you're
going through something. May Allah make
it easy on you. And I'm not trying to
And I'm not And I'm not trying to
belittle you here. But I'm saying this,
okay? I'm not being condescending. Let
me tell you something. For you to come
and say something so sacred like the
family unit, yeah? What did she say?
Basically, what she's saying in a
nutshell, this family unit that you have
is so sacred, yeah? But, don't put up
with it. You know the feminist
narrative. No. Yeah, Miss Independent.
Destroy it. Basically, she's saying
destroy it.
Put yourself before your children. This
is a selfish attitude.
It's a selfish attitude. And guess what?
It is so selfish that the mother who's
been advised by this sister is basically
being told that even if it comes at the
cost of your children, destroy it. And
what is the What's what's waiting for
you better on the other side? Let's put
it. Do you really think No, no, one
second.
One second.
Sisters sisters think
Let me tell you something.
Sisters think that the the husband that
practice polygamy, that when they
divorce, they're going to go to another
person that's not polygamous. I repeat
again. Every man is polygamous. This is
what the sisters don't understand. They
think there is a man out there
the knight in shining armor, the white
knight in shining armor, yeah? Okay.
Is is waiting for them. No, you're going
to get the same issue in a different
way. If he doesn't If he If he fears
you, audhubillah, he's going to go and
do it behind your back in the wrong way.
Or guess what? If he fears Allah, he's
going to do it in the right way. Or, you
know what? If he fears Allah he's going
to hide it because
tells you, you're going to cause chaos
and havoc, yeah? So,
what I'm going to say is to sister I
think her name is Sumayya. Sister
Sumayya, fear Allah. With all due
respect, please do not ever talk about
this topic, period, yeah? For you to
come and give this advice. Look, you can
come and say you know what? It wasn't
for me. Or whatever Or I know somebody
went through it was very like whatever
it may be. Wallahi, you guys didn't talk
about how it was done in the wrong way.
You did a full out attack, a lethal
attack, an atomic a nuclear warhead on
polygamy itself. And it turned into a
horror movie. It's worse than paranormal
activity. And you are here coming and
saying basically
the family the intact house, destroy it.
I'm so sorry. Wallahi, and 200,000
people watch this. Fear Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. A sister who is involved in
polygamy, her husband is going married
again. Wallahi, let me tell you
something. God knows how many marriages
you destroyed.
God knows how many
I'm going to do more. Let them get ready
for it. Okay. Let me tell you something,
yeah? Okay, good.
Call it call it whatever you like, okay?
Call it call it whatever you like.
Subhanallah. Yeah? The point is this,
okay? Do you not talk about these
matters, okay? Please, please do not
talk about these matters. You don't know
how delicate the family unit is. And you
don't know how fragile our sisters are.
They've already been attacked by
feminists. On top of that, we have our
sisters in hijabs giving advice of the
intact family unit. Selfish. Destroy it.
Bro, imagine this.
I'm so sorry to say it.
You know what? Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. What did they say in the
video? They said we don't mind brothers
coming. Open open discussion. I would
like to invite sister Sumayya. I would
like to invite all the sisters that were
on there to come to have a discussion, a
civilized discussion on this topic at
hand. If you genuinely care about the
ummah, which we have no doubt you do,
please, I would invite you. I'm doing
I'm doing a little new show. Have a
little discussion on gender roles, etc.
I would like to invite our sisters to
come.
Me, myself, you, and maybe brother
Zeeshan. Let's talk about this as your
brothers and sisters and let's give a
solution, a correct way of practicing
polygamy. I would invite our sisters.
I think what you said there is
absolutely right. I mean,
one book that's pretty easy to read
about the problems of a single a single
parent household
is The Boy Crisis, yeah, for example, by
Warren Farrell. Now, this this
particular book I mean, I I can't have
time to enumerate the kind of statistics
that he puts in this book about how much
a single mother puts a child in a
disadvantage from an educational
perspective, from a It increases their
chances
Yeah, I get you. Of course. No. We're
saying that's what's the consequence. Of
course. I'm saying that, you know,
criminal delinquency,
educational levels, all these kinds of
things. You're putting them in a in a
disadvantage position. Before in our
history, in our illustrious history, our
mothers and fathers used to fight wars
for us. They used to No, honestly, they
used to the the traumas that they
actually went through,
quite frankly, were something that would
put us all to shame, including me and
you. All of us to shame. And now we're
talking about
a marriage setup as if it is
uh you know, a cancer cancer or an
which which which which will destroy
you. And there's no way
there is no way of you being able to
adapt to it. No, no, let me let me give
you some figures, yeah? Kids from single
mother homes, 63% of you of all youth
suicides single mother homes. 90% of
homelessness and runaway children from
single mother homes. 85% of behavioral
disorders single mother homes. 80% of
rapists with anger issues single mother
homes. 71% of high school dropouts
single mother homes. 80% of all youth in
prison single mother homes. I'll give a
disclaimer. I'm not saying the mothers
are to blame. I'm saying this from a
single mother home. So, you're basically
saying that's what's intact? Destroy it.
Yeah, and imagine if they all had their
fathers. And by the way, this can be the
fathers from Maybe the father left and
went.
Yes, what I'm saying is the selfish
decision of the father or the mother is
coming at the consequences of a ripple
effect of the children. You you actually
throwing your children in the fire.
Throw your children in the fire. It's
this gender egoism. Or it's micro
feminism. Gender egoism selfishness.
It's gender egoism. I would never give
advice
to anyone the way that she has right
now.
It is is At the end of the day, it's
individualism. It is egoism and
individualism. It's selfish. You're
teaching them self You're not teaching
them Islam. You're not teaching them
sabr. So, instead of sabr,
instead of all of these verses in the
Quran in the beginning of the ayah all
the all the Quran, sorry, all the way to
the end, yes.
Not these ayahs.
Let's instead think about counseling.
Maybe a secular counselor. Because you
know there's a gig culture. Let's think
about breaking the house. Let's not
think about a family intact. This is
diabolical. You know what's very
important? Just to finish on this. I'm
so sorry, yeah? Listen, look, sisters,
you listen to that, yeah? Was there one
Quran and sunnah there? She didn't
mention one ayah. Okay, one second. That
shows me it's nothing it's nothing but
coming from the aql. Not even the aql,
from her emotions. And only if it was
the No problem.
Please break it from the aql, sister.
LOOK, NO PROBLEM. NO PROBLEM, YEAH? If
you go If If somebody goes to a person
of knowledge and says my husband got
married again. And if that person speak
from the Quran, the ayahs that you
quoted, wallahi, at least it would aid
the woman. I say, "You know what?
Patience." Calling her to truth. Yes.
Calling her to like stuff to maintain
the family unit, etc. We're not talking
about a husband that comes and punches
you in the face, doesn't look after you,
doesn't provide.
We're talking about who's doing all
these things, but decided to get married
again.
Yeah, and he's still with you. He hasn't
divorced. He's still You're saying,
"You're my wife. I love you." He's And
he got married again. And because of
this, he's vilified, turned into a
vampire, Dracula, sucking blood, a
horror movie. Look at the level they
went to. Not a single Quran ayah. And
but when you go to the kitab of Allah,
look how Allah consoles you. And look
how Allah tells you to be patient, yeah?
And tells you what is better. Wallahi,
this is the reason why any kind of
man-made law or woman-made law or any
kind of opinions that are spewed out
with no Quran and sunnah, run a mile.
I'm telling you, run a mile. That's all
I have to say. And I think that's a good
place to end. And I think I will end as
well with a very famous quote I saw from
Victor Frankl, which he wrote a book
called The Meaning of Life.
Very powerful. And he introduced
something called logotherapy, by the
way,
which is it focuses on meaning and the
why behind, you know. And it's a really
powerful way from a religious
perspective how someone can attach
themselves to meaning.
And And just like Nietzsche said, you
know, if you have a why, almost any how
is possible. If a woman's going through
this, look, first of all, we don't want
to diminish from what you're going
through. It's a very difficult
situation. It really is, yeah? However,
if there's a why, and your why is
strong, you will be rewarded by Allah
subhana wa
almost any how is possible. You'll be
able to get through this polygamy.
You'll do it for your children. You'll
do it for your family. You'll do it for
yourself.
And you will get rewarded in the
hereafter as well.
But something which Victor Frankl
himself said, which I think was very
interesting, is I think it applies in
these situations, in this situation of a
woman who's the mother that's not very
happy with the person who she married,
and the woman the first wife. In both
situations and many situations like it.
Is that when you have when you can no
longer change a situation,
then you have to try and change
yourself.
You know, and at the end of the day, if
for me as an individual, if I was going
through something difficult in life,
something uncomfortable, I would want my
people around me
to give me words which will increase my
resilience,
my toughness, my strength. I'm sorry to
say, but if if you are being
charged with all of these kinds of uh
micro-feministic phrases, trauma,
bullying, suicide using the word
suicide. I mean, using all kinds of
words. How is that meant to engender
empowerment? How is that meant to
engender strength and toughness and
resilience within Muslim people? It's
not even negative. It's un-Islamic. It's
shameful. It's humiliating. And it
should be repented for. And I don't care
And you know, I expect maybe some people
say, "Well, this is they're very upset.
They're very I don't To be honest, I
don't care
You have no right to come
and affect children,
young children, with your poisonous and
misinformed advice. You should repent.
You should ask for forgiveness. And you
should delete those videos. And if you
delete your videos, maybe most of them,
because all of them have this kind of
tone with very limited ayahs in the
Quran, which you claim to believe, and
the hadith, which you also claim to
believe,
and start a fresh with the Quran and
sunnah in front of you. Otherwise, you
are creating mischief in the land. Was
salaam alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. The Prophet Muhammad
alayhi wasallam told us
that when the son of Adam dies, all of
his good deeds are interrupted. They are
finished
except for three things.
Sadaqah tun Jariyah.
A continuous charity, and a beneficial
knowledge, and also a a righteous
offspring that makes dua for him. Your
brothers and sisters in Islam net from
Norway are establishing a masjid, a
Dawah center, and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do.
Whenever someone prays there, whenever
someone gives Shahadah in the masjid,
whenever someone learns something in the
masjid,
yes,
that will be something that you will
have on your scale.
So, give generously, and Allah Azza wa
Jal will give you even more.